reality TV if you've been watching the
show you know that I hate it and I've
got a little good news for you it is
starting to crumble yeah that's right
according to LA Times ratings for
reality TV you're totally in the toilet
and we've got a couple examples for you
Fox lost 50 million dollars on utopia
did either one of you guys see utopia by
any chance it was a disaster was on for
about three weeks about a bunch of
people they tried to create a futuristic
civilization together is terrible NBC's
The Voice which was pretty big for a
couple seasons so it's season finale
dropped nearly ten percent this month
duck dynasty that's a show it's a bunch
of Hick's that ducks or something
that's not like a sound like that uh the
ratings have plunged TLC cancelled here
comes honey boo boo now apparently that
wasn't totally cuz of ratings but I
guess Boo Boo's mom had sex with her
brother or something no so the close to
that I ex-offender she was a sex
offender yeah close enough and AMC
largely abandoned a three-year foray
into unscripted programming so I think
these are all good signs because reality
TV is just awful and we've been
bludgeoned to death with Kardashians and
all this just awful housewife nonsense
as media guys this has got to feel
pretty good right well one thing that I
find interesting about the the articles
that talk about how the networks in
general are losing their audience to
cable and one cable doesn't do reality
as much as the networks do but it and
it's true of course the networks are
declining and they don't have the market
show that they had before an American
Idol is another one that is declining
yeah but they always talk about as if
it's a zero-sum game between the cable
you know cable viewers and network
viewers and then they might talk about
Netflix in the new new Amazon coming out
with their own show the programming but
nobody ever talked about YouTube which I
feel like that's where they're losing a
lot of their viewership is to YouTube
like you people a few good people and if
there's there's not an acknowledgment
it's like there there's only in that's
because they don't they don't live in
the world of young people yeah I mean
used to be when you're a teenager for a
lot of people you come home from school
you throw it on your backpack and turn
on TV and you watch TV now those kids go
up to the room and turn on YouTube and
so where they factored in it right so to
that point so let's just stick on that
for a sec before we go back to reality
TV to that point is this
so just like a generational thing sort
of like we were talking about in the
previous segment on the Middle East that
all the people that are in the business
that controlled the money they did grow
up throwing their backpack watching TV
after school etc etc so those are the
adults now controlling the money versus
YouTube almost anyone under 40 at this
point gets almost everything online so
there's a big disconnect between the
decision-makers in programming and media
and the people who are the consumers of
that media and I mean I give them a
little bit more credit because they
don't say the word you too but they do
mention how they're losing audiences to
the internet which usually talking about
like Netflix and they don't they don't
acknowledge YouTube as because like
there are shows on YouTube and there are
people who subscribe I don't think they
even understand right i guess that is
that's the mole that's the thing that
YouTube hasn't crossed yet like there
there isn't the breakout sort of orange
is the new black or transparent or
something like that so I guess that's
what you probably hate YouTube is
working on that right now yeah yeah so
back to the issue of reality shows yeah
I think there's a I think there's two
basic types so one is like the game show
essentially right so like American Idol
even survivor those are kind of game
contest yeah contest of some sort
and I think there's always always a
market for that because people want to
see that and that's actually reality and
of course there's also some some editing
that that goes into it to give it some
flavor so certain contestants are more
likable than others yeah so we get that
but there but that's gonna be there the
other kind of rally program is just a
pure voyeuristic type so so we want to
peek into the Real Housewives want to
peek into duck dynasty honey boo boo and
a lot of it is just a just a spectacle
watching you would we want to see
something that's up and yeah and
you know extreme from one from one to
the other range of normal behavior right
that to me is gonna die and mate and
that naini because the novelty has worn
off and it's not even reality it's
completely fake it's also more quickly
yeah it's essentially scripted but it's
just cheaper and with with less likable
characters I think and so I think that's
gonna
weh-weh scaled back uh so that actually
might be saying that YouTube actually
hasten the death of because once they
put webcams in people's rooms you could
actually see reality yeah so it sort of
made the reality of the cuz it's all
scripted unscripted nonsense but I think
you make good point about sort of the
game show aspect verse whatever because
to me you are watch reality TV I could
turn on the price is right at any time
and it's always entertaining I mean I
haven't watched it and God knows how
long but you could always turn it on for
five minutes and something sort of fun
is happening and you're seeing real
people and there's something actually
and it's not about that voyeuristic
right and we all I mean look we
all love watching people win stuff right
so like a half time of a basketball game
in a guy makes a half-court shot any
wins $50,000 who doesn't love the place
goes nuts in the arena and on television
you know halftime of bowl games that
they have scholarships that people win
from throwing footballs or catching
footballs so we love that stuff we love
it and there's always a market for that
right we love yes you will reality yeah
that's what you're saying yeah yeah well
that's like my question is that people
are people becoming more savvy I don't
like to give the American public any
credit yes you can see from the back
teeth earlier earlier segments Vesta who
we admire but I wonder if people are
beginning to say you know they see the
ad for the Keeping Up with the
Kardashians like oh you know Kim and her
mother getting a big fight over who's
gonna you know and we know that that is
totally phony and made up and they just
completely manufactured for our benefit
and you know how many times can we watch
Real Housewives rip out fake hair
extensions you know I mean in getting
these terrible fights like we've
literally they went from ripping out
hair extensions ripping off a leg did
you see that there was an episode of one
of them Beverly Hills or something where
a woman actually ripped her prosthetic
leg off and threw it at somebody so that
made us a moment at all that may have
been mowing to jump the shark without a
leg but wait alright so finally my
question is potentially we are just
wising up that this isn't reality yeah
and it's and if you want to watch
scripted shows there's much better
scripted shows than keeping up with the
kardashians on netflix or on amazon or
somewhere else yeah and you know we're
on AMC or but mostly not on the
network's but not on the network so that
that basically is my final point that
the
there is actually good TV now so is that
the other thing that may be right
through this horrible 10-year span that
we went through this that television
actually did make a comeback no I think
television is at its finest in his
history I think there are more good
shows on television now than ever before
and and it shows maybe from from HBO but
like Game of Thrones boardwalk empire
you know these are outstanding shows and
and even shows like that I don't watch
but walking dead is very popular
Breaking Bad Mad Men there's so many
good shows on television that's
available both on TV and also on netflix
and hulu you watch that you don't watch
this honey boo boo nonsense you
know steve is by the way pain spokesman
for AMC nhp Oh everybody yeah let you
know baby please yeah on your behalf but
watch this watch this Malcolm's a paid
spokesmen for the reuben report so tell
them what they should do when they're
done watching this it should drive down
down there and look at this and then you
know like like like like like and
comment below that's right